in the middle of the night a sudden
massive explosion
and a fireball blindingly bright even on
this grainy footage
it happened just before 4am in the built
up Harbor area of Saint Helia an entire
block of flats raised to the ground we
have a three-story building that has
completely collapsed
described as from a demolition point of
view probably as a pancake that has just
dropped almost sort of straight down the
as you will have seen I'm sure from some
of the pictures that are already
circulating it is a considerable
destruction
but in terms of casualties the scale of
the destruction is not yet known as many
as a dozen are believed to be missing
and it's feared there may be more
fatalities
my thoughts and prayers are foremost
with the families of those who have died
and those who are still waiting for news
of their loved ones and those who also
have been forced from their homes today
I want to offer my sincerest and
heartfelt thanks to our emergency
service responders who have been on the
scene since the early hours of this
morning and all of those who have worked
to make the site safe enough to begin
the search process
specialist teams from the UK have
arrived to help that process which will
continue throughout the night but police
have warned it may take days given the
extent of the rubble a huge operation is
also underway to make the site safe with
pockets of fire still reportedly burning
while dozens of local residents have
been evacuated and taken to the town
hall because of the damage to
neighboring buildings some of those at
the Town Hall came here having had their
Windows blown in others just had to grab
whatever clothing they couldn't put it
on and uh
with their pets some people came didn't
even grab their phones they just came
straight down here what caused this
blast is still not known but the fire
service confirmed it was called to the
area on Friday evening around eight
hours earlier after residents reported
smelling gas police say that will now be
the focus of their investigation